we loved watching Quicksilver save the
X-Men at supersonic speeds but wait
until you get a look at Evan Peters
having air blown into his face while he
runs on a treadmill and did you know
that alligator Loki was actually a
stuffed animal these are movies that
look hilarious without CGI that's right
one of the coolest scenes in the movie
was mostly performed in front of a green
screen and for those close-up shots of
Evan Peter's face we have Kevin the
actor on a treadmill and that wasn't all
they were blowing massive amounts of air
at my face to get it that rippled look
now that's a look and you're never gonna
find apocalypse intimidating again once
you see him break out his sick dance
moves there seems to be something of a
dance epidemic on set in fact everyone
was getting into it watching this
definitely makes us wonder how Goro
would move on the dance floor with all
those extra arms how do you create a
massive forearmed Shogun for Live Action
surprisingly enough this has actually
been done in a few ways throughout the
years for the 1995 movie Goro was
brought to life using a massive
animatronic suit that director Paul W S
Anderson described as a diva because of
the hours of setup required for each
take for HBO Max they decided to go a
little more old school with it literally
we had oh my God one of the one in front
fighting him with four arms the giant
head might be the best part it's a lot
funnier watching two Ninjas in
morphsuits fighting Cole young but hey
at least he wasn't a stuffed animal yes
alligator Loki is one of the strangest
additions to the show he's a Loki
variant who happens to be an alligator
in all its growling crowned Glory hang
on you're telling me that thing's a Loki
too oh yes but as you can probably guess
having a live alligator on set can be
risky and so they decided to go the CGI
route instead and used a blue stuffed
animal as a stand-in on set and when it
came time for the alligator to Chomp
down on a Loki varian's hand they just
had the stuffed animal tossed across the
set it was almost as ridiculous as not
being subscribed to our channel so just
make sure to hit that red button before
we move on to a tale as old as time it's
a love story for the ages a beauty and
her Beast of sorts to play the beast in
Disney's live-action movie Dan Stevens
had to wear a mix between a motion
capture suit and a puppeteering of a big
muscle suit on stilt so I was inside
this this 40 pound thing Not only was
this suit silly looking enough on its
own but it forced poor Dan to move so
stiffly that his dancing scene with Emma
looks more like the hostage situation it
actually is it looks like she's dancing
with some sort of awkward muscle man but
we'll give Dan this at least he looks
tougher than Ben Affleck did in his
motion capture suit as Batman the bat
suit for Donna Justice was unlike any
other we'd seen before it had more of a
heavy armored look about it and a real
suit actually was constructed for Ben
Affleck to wear in the movie but we made
a determination that we wanted to use
the real mech suit it definitely grounds
the fight in reality but the suit was
just a little too heavy for some of the
highly detailed fight scenes they had
planned you can't move in that suit that
much where we did use the motion capture
suit the result looked a lot like two
grown men wrestling in their pajamas
motion capture suits really can ruin the
best of moments just look at the
Romantic scenes from Avatar who Among Us
wasn't astounded to see the world of
Pandora brought to life on the big
screen the navi looked like they could
have come from real life but the reality
is a lot less glamorous than it would
appear instead Our Stars were all
traipsing around wearing motion capture
suits complete with pointed ears tails
and colorful dreadlocks for some reason
they look almost as nerdy as our
Avengers did on set and just watch Sam
Worthington getting pummeled by
stagehands before getting jerked around
on strings to act out being attacked by
Pandora's Wildlife but the best part
just has to be the massive headgear that
really gets in the way of some of the
more romantic moments watching our
heroes come to blows on an Airport
runway was one of the best moments in
Civil War how cool was it getting to see
Spider-Man in action for the very first
time although the real life version of
Spider-Man leaves something to be
desired with those dead eyes but he's
got nothing on Iron Man and War Machine
both of whom seem to be outfitted in
leggings and ski boots in place of their
super suits all in all everything about
this scene just feels so much less
impressive when you're watching it all
play out in front of a green screen but
hey at least nobody had to dress up as a
giant shark a giant humanoid shark
shouldn't be this cute right I'm a
little surprised people find him utterly
adorable we all loved king shark in the
movie and while you may already know
that Sylvester Stallone lended his voice
to the character I wear this guy what
you may not have realized was that
comedian Steve Agee stood in for him on
set James was like well we need somebody
tall and I was like oh thank God I think
I'm James tallest friend the only
problem was poor Steve needed to be
dressed up in a padded motion caption
suit and full headpiece plus a
displacement suit that would help the
other actors know not to stand too close
to him or as Margot Robbie described it
weird thing on his head which you get
used to weirdly quickly this might have
to be one of the most embarrassing looks
on this list from our forearmed fighters
to blue aliens sometimes CGI really does
make movies look a whole lot better
which one of these hilarious examples
were your favorite and are there any
other movies that look funnier without
special effects that you can think of
we'd love to hear what you think so make
sure to let us know down in the comment
section
[Music]